hey welcome to my Bommel course before
we get started I first want to make sure
that you're familiar with scrim ba scrim
bow is this interactive platform that
you're using you can record and edit
other people's screencasts and see the
changes in real times if I have a
website here you can actually copy edit
the code say let's say hello Roma save
it and then that will be reflected in
the browser so everything that I do here
you can do it as well or copied and save
it as your own all right this is my
beaumont course and in it you're gonna
learn how to use MoMA MoMA is a modern
CSS framework from Jeremy Thomas who
goes by Jake Adams it's based on flexbox
and using MoMA we can describe our
websites design using just classes
flexbox is a newer CSS spec that makes
sectioning and aligning more natural we
don't need to know flexbox but it is how
boma works behind the scenes and when I
say classes what I mean is that instead
of writing around a CSS per element you
can use it predefined classes this is
really what the bulk of boma is and with
enough classes we can describe our
websites design using just semantics
so before we deconstruct what that means
take a look at the icons that you see
below with OMA we can prototype columns
form elements components modifiers
layout elements and elements themselves
the way that we interact with a boma is
first we use this template this is the
standard template that you would use
when you start to author any MoMA
website I've added one line of code and
this is so that we can understand our
website it's just a CSS debugger if you
want to enable it you can just uncomment
this line and see that it looks a bit
different we'll use that to make sure
that our website is designed perfectly
other than that this is where bulma is
getting linked to our website and then
this these are font awesome icons this
will load it up into your website okay
we were talking about classes before
this area right over here
well boma is styling classes for us and
with enough classes we can make a really
robust and response website this for
example would create the website that
I've been showing you so far which
already out of the box is responsive
doesn't mean a lot so far but it will
going forward okay this is a boma
website and it's one of the three
websites that we're going to learn to
make in these screencasts this is what
it would look like on a mobile device
and on the right a tablet device whereas
this was the desktop and then we're
going to learn how to make a beautiful
blog I already created a course for this
but this one will be using boma and will
take a fraction of the time
instead of 40 minutes you'll be able to
do this in maybe 15 or so minutes then
after that we're gonna make a launch
page for a product here I've recreated
the Tesla Roadster page this is not the
actual page it's just my version of it
it is responsive and that's how it would
look on a mobile and a tablet device
alright so this is pretty exciting stuff
if you have any questions or comments
you want to reach out to me you can
click my face reach out to me on Twitter
otherwise I think we're ready to get
started alright I'll see you in the next
screencast where we'll first build this
website and then that will slowly turn
into this one all right I'll see you
there
hey welcome back so in this screencast
we're going to turn this website into
this one this actually is a website and
then we'll use this as a base to add
some complexity and make it a bit
prettier until we get all the way back
up to our original slide which again is
responsive so on a mobile device this
and then as a tablet on the right
alright so how do we begin just to start
let me point out that we have a few
folders and files ready to go I have our
images that we use across all of our
websites and then I have some of almost
documentation this is by no means all of
boma this is maybe 10 or 15% if I had to
guess might be much less than that
but the point is that way Poma works is
that we have our classes and these
classes usually follow some HTML
contract and that means that our boma is
pretty idiomatic and that another boma
developer could look at our website and
just by looking at these contracts
understand our website so looking at our
website this is the first thing that we
see and in our code we have a section a
better component that we could use
instead of a section is a hero so
section is more generic whereas hero
signifies it's important it's the first
thing that we see so now we don't have
very much let's go ahead and look at the
debugger and we can see that the element
is occupying just a portion but by no
means all the height so what we can do
is hero has a modifier called is full
height modifiers allowed to just modify
some other class and in this case is
full height is limited to hero you can't
use it everywhere we're also going to
add another modifier as background black
turning off our debugger okay so often
when you want to put something inside of
a hero or a section you put a container
we can see that the container is trying
to create a space for us to put some
content okay and then in our container
I'm going to add a image so we're gonna
add the image contract and put that
right in here you might be wondering why
do we need to specify the dimension what
can happen is that the website will
resize itself because the images are
loading and images can occupy a
different height when they're unloaded
as opposed to when they are loaded and
so to avoid this behavior you can just
specify what the dimensions are so there
are predefined dimensions but you can
also use an aspect ratio if you need
more generalized dimensions now in this
case we don't actually need this because
our website is so simple right and then
we'll swap out image source with our
actual logo so say voila or the light
which was in here right there and then
that's in our images folder so we're
almost there we definitely need to
constrain the width so I'll just add X
width and we'll say maybe 512 pixels all
right and then last we want to Center it
so here I'm going to add a style tag
this is how we can interpolate our own
CSS with homeless or create a center
class which is just a generic centering
class and then justify content is for
the horizontal centering so we do use
Center as the value and then align items
is for the vertical centering the center
class will Center whatever element is
inside of it so we'll go up one element
and we'll put it in here and it's
centered we'll turn off the debugger and
now we have a responsive website albeit
pretty boring that's it for this one in
the next one we are going to add some
columns and make it a bit more like an
actual website all right I'll see you in
the next screencast
hey welcome back so this is the state of
our website it's terrible and what we
can do to make it a bit better we're
going to add a section so this is the
hero at the tops the first thing that
you see underneath we have a section and
so we pretty much know how to do that
we'll add the columns class and then
three columns
now we'll add some text and then we're
on our way first things first let's go
to our Docs and then get these section
that right here so let's get rid of our
is full height see how that looks and
then let's make these size a bit smaller
so I'll reduce it by a factor of two
it cool looks good and then now we're
gonna add some columns they'll go back
to the moment dock and then here's
columns okay so we'll just put that
there
turn on the debugger and then let's take
a look so we have a column a single
column occupying pretty much the full
containers with what if we had two
columns it's pretty smart here and it
can figure this out for us we don't
actually need to state how many columns
we desire we can pretty much just put it
right in here so we know that we're
going to have three so I'll just add one
more and then we can add in some text
and then we'll turn off the debugger
it's not quite the same so what's going
on you can see that there is an area
around the text but the text here is
occupying pretty much the full column
there's no padding there's no margin
let's take a closer look
alright there's no gap so what's going
on well what we can do is can add a
container inside of here but instead of
container when you use what's called a
notification in a notification will give
it this sort of gray style that you see
here so we're going to wrap the text in
a notification class
and see that it's got some area around
it now
yeah all right looks good all right
looks great now what's so cool about
flexbox and boma and all this stuff is
that it can do a lot of the heavy
lifting for us so here's what I mean
if I resize or it's already responsive
we didn't actually need to do very much
to do that and you're here responsive
design you have to have media queries
and then you have to understand how
everything connects to each other but
boma understands these ideas and pretty
much takes out the labor for us so
that's awesome it's optimized for
tablets desktops and mobile devices out
of the box now I want to point out that
notification can be modified just like
we used has background black before you
can use other modifiers so for example I
can do is primary and take a look how
the text is white and the background is
green whereas over here the text is
black and the background is gray all
right now the last thing is if we want
to control the text we can add a
modifier so we'll need to wrap this in
its own paragraph is size so we can do
you like is three and you can see it got
really really big so much that it's
overwhelming believe there's one through
seven and what we use for now is five so
just a bit bigger and that's it in the
next screencast when I add those is
primary and some others to make this
really beautiful and then add a title
for each of these columns all right I'll
see you in the next screencast
hey welcome back so this is the state of
a website not bad but we're gonna
improve it with some color so it'll look
like this by the time that we're
finished which I think looks a lot
better so how do we do that how do we go
from here there all right so we know we
need to remove the background make this
the color logo because that is a
different one than it is here and then
we can give the columns their own
background and then add a title and then
add a color to our notification all
right so that is pretty straightforward
okay so like we mentioned we'll get rid
of the has background black it'll
default to a white but now our logo is
invisible so we can go to our images and
then we're gonna swap out the white one
for this one alright just like that nice
that's a bit big so let's change that
max width
so now we don't have a partition between
our hero and the section to make that
more obvious let me point that out with
the debugger so here we can see that
there's a beginning and an end to the
hero and the section to make that more
obvious we need to add a color that's
why this one looks a bit different so
we'll go to section I'm gonna add has
background and I'm gonna use light for
this nice so now we have a problem we
can't see our column from the section
right we need to be able to separate
these two so what we can do is add a
modifier to our notification right here
we can do is and then of the available
ones we have I think there's info is
linked and you have danger warning and
primary right so these would all happen
is before them so let's see what they
look like just turning off the deep
bugger
so yeah link gives us a nice blue - feel
free to experiment with these I'm going
to use is info is primary and then is
warning now let's really cool about
using these thematic modifiers is they
actually modify more than just the
background take a look at the text the
text has now altered firm black to white
depending on which theme we're using so
this is a really nice feature of OMA
well we'll inverse the text in this case
to make sure that it's readable if we
force this to be a has text white right
here
it's not as readable as before so this
is one of the things that boma is doing
for us behind the scenes that I think is
really cool now we only need to add a
title so what we can do is we're going
to add an H element so do h1 and then
we'll do what was it oh yeah almost the
first one and that does not look good
that looks so inferior all right so
let's attribute this so right now it's
not getting anything from MoMA because
it doesn't have a class so I'm going to
give it a say title now we get something
that stands out that's a bit big so I
add a modifier to per title and we'll do
is size to do I think one less yeah that
looks good that's pretty quick right so
Roma is doing a lot of the work for us
now we're ready to move on to adding the
columns that you see beneath all right
I'll see you in the next screencast
hey welcome back so our website looks
like this which is alright I mean it's a
bit boring but what we can do is
beautify it so we're gonna give it some
pecans and then another section and then
that section will have its own cut icons
that have a color and then the title and
the paragraph will hug each other here
so how do we do this
we're gonna go to the boma documentation
and we're gonna grab two classes we need
the media class which is like a Facebook
post or a Twitter post
and then we need to grab the actual icon
class which is here all right and I'm
going to put that right in here we have
our media left which is this area over
here and then inside of it we need to
put the icon class which is what we did
here okay and then our content well we
already have content it's here so we're
just going to insert that right here and
that's really it so let's go ahead and
refactor this combine our notification
with the media class so we'll do media
notification and then all we need to do
is we'll make this article this article
and then we'll get rid of this guy
alright so let's see how this looks got
the wrong icon but it's a start the icon
that will actually use is this one and I
didn't memorize that that is coming from
an awesome com so that's where we get
the codes for the font awesome icons and
we don't want this to have a color so we
can just get rid of that for now our
icon is appearing as white because of
his info and that's pretty interesting
if I put is warning the icon goes black
that's a really nice feature to make the
icon bigger we can add a modifier here
let's say FA LG for large and you also
have 2x and then every X and there's
probably more so with you 2x for now I
think that's the right size yeah that
looks really good now if you want it to
have more of an area around the icon
I'll show you what I mean yeah that box
is like really narrow it doesn't have
that sort of nice area around it an easy
way to fix that is we can add a modifier
to the icon class of is medium or as
large or try it as large yeah so that
red definitely makes a difference and
then let's turn off the bugger so it's a
bit big let's just make that is medium
instead cool yeah so that's really all
there is to making this a media class
who's gonna paste in the results pepper
use act code that we wrote before just
copied and pasted and yeah the rest of
it is really the same thing so let's go
ahead and just take all of this copy and
paste it again
all right and we know that we're gonna
have six instead of three so we're gonna
repeat the column so instead we have six
columns and that does not look good so
we need to fix this how do we how do we
fix that so we can add a few things for
every column we need to say it's one
third there's a whole bunch of modifiers
in use here we're gonna use is one third
and then this will basically force each
column to occupy one third of the
website's width so we just repeat that
process and then let's see how that
looks
all right that's a bit better but it's
definitely on at the same line which is
not ideal hope you had another modifier
called
is multi-line and then this will force
it to break Thanks
now you probably know what to do here
right what do we what's left we can get
rid of the background for the whole
section the notification doesn't need to
have a color now it's great okay so
let's just go ahead and force that so we
say it has that ground white in our
paragraph to make these hug to make this
hug the title you can just give the
class of subtitle now finally we're just
gonna make this a little smaller and
then get rid of this space around the
icon we can give it a color by doing has
text let's say warning I'm gonna go and
paste in the results and then we'll load
that up and what up it's really that
cool and it's all responsive which is
really amazing because we didn't we
didn't even need to code that right one
was doing all of this for us so bomb was
really incredible at rapidly prototyping
and shipping websites quickly and then
coming up we're going to learn how to on
the blog I'll see you in the next
screencast
hey welcome back so you just finished
your first Bulma website and that's
really amazing just how much fun looking
new for you you think about it you did
responsive beautiful website design
without even touching was it any CSS
like it was it's like for hot it's like
five lines of CSS so bomb was really a
powerhouse here and understanding and
mastering boma can really I mean the
thing is even if you don't use boa in
production it can teach you how Jeremy
or Jake Adams might solve a problem
using boma and I think that's pretty
amazing all right let's start up our new
website this is going to be a blog and
to start you'll note that we have this
little breadcrumb at the top so let's go
ahead and paste that in one of the
components that we can use is the bread
crumb so it's right here note that we're
starting with the section in the
container if we're not starting with the
hero it makes sense that we would start
with a section instead alright so put
that right here and then let's take a
look and it doesn't do anything because
it's empty so I'm just filling with
values
all right so that looks really great now
let's go ahead and open it up and it's
okay but in our design here the contents
pretty narrow so how do we how do we
change that so I couldn't find a hundred
percent idiomatic way to do this with
bulma's so instead I relied on CSS grid
so now we're going to learn how to embed
CSS grid into boma and so here's what we
can do create a grid class which
requires it need display grid then when
a template three columns because you can
imagine that this website is really just
three columns the container is the
reason that this doesn't go all the way
to the edge of the web page that's why
we have a gap here but if we just ignore
that gap we basically have a small
column a bigger column and then a
another small column over here well what
we can do
grid template columns and we're going to
divide our website into thirds to start
so we've new one if our one if our one
fr fr stands for a fraction unit so now
our websites being divided into thirds
anywhere we put the grid class this one
okay now we need to be pretty explicit
here because if we just use grid as it
is the content will fall into this
column so because almost always the
content falls into this column we just
need to be explicit about that you
belong to the second before the third
column I want the content to start here
and then end here so the syntax is two
over three and then we can just put the
grid here because of our content is
inside of this div we put the grid here
and the asterisk is referring to
anything inside of the grid that would
include this nav that will inherit this
grid com rule okay so we go ahead and
load this up our websites divided into
thirds now with the content occupying
just the center column it's a bit too
narrow so what we can do instead is
we'll give this a fixed width all right
that's great
and let's turn on the debugger so if we
make this responsive oh and I forgot it
off right there okay all right so
looking with the debugger see this
little these white lines right here well
that's because our column
is too wide on a mobile device it can't
be 624 pixels that might be wider than
the screen and say this is a responsive
column with a minimum and a maximum
width anywhere from 0 to 624 pixels so
now you'll note that we don't get that
side effect so that's great all right
how we how do we get these bigger images
if you look on a mobile device you'll
note that they occupy the full width
whereas on a desktop device
it's just occupying most of the width so
remember the reason we have this gap
here is because of the container given
that what's called this column medium
and I can update this it's really
amazing that grid is that subtle and
then now if I wanted to refer to all
three columns which is pretty much what
this design is these images are spanning
all three columns then I'll just create
another identifier and then here I'll
use Excel okay and then to use our new
excel identifiers I need to create a
class so that we can give a specific
element say for example nav occupy all
three columns and not just the the
center medium column
so now I wanted our nav to occupy all
three columns I can just give it the
class of grid Excel wait a minute what's
what's going on we've got this gap right
here well that's actually boma trying to
help us out almost trying to make
everything pretty but in this case it's
adding padding and we don't want it it's
interrupting the design what we can do
this would new is padding less here so
this tells the section to not have its
own padding there we go
right now it's occupying all three so
that's great and let's go ahead and turn
this off and now it's just occupying the
the content column it looks like we can
keep the vertical padding it's just the
horizontal padding that that we don't
care for so let's go ahead and make our
own class because it doesn't exist in
Omaha but we'll just make it real quick
so we say is padding less horizontal
we'd say padding left I mean right right
okay and then let's see what happens
oh I just realized we mistyped hang on
okay it's better now all right so we
created the class and now it's occupying
the full width which is really really
what we want we want to have a hundred
percent control of the layout in this
case now we're gonna have a problem
which is our content doesn't hug the
wall but our image does ooh how do we do
with that well it's actually pretty
subtle something has the class of grid
excel we just don't care about it but in
general we want it to have a small
gutter so the way that we can do this is
very subtle right we put a extra column
right here and right here now no matter
what there will always be a 1.5 RM which
valuates - I think 24 pixels there
always be a gutter to the left and the
right of our content column and then the
one if R is just the the remainder space
so check this out it's really it's
really amazing right so we load up the
web page and now we've got that gutter
so so that's good and then we go ahead
and put grid excel and then it's gone so
it's really that easy for us to define
the
laying out using CSS grid and still
embed it into our boma so we get the
benefits of both CSS grid and OMA next
we're going to learn how to make this
author thing at the top and then we'll
make the title and I'll see you in the
next screencast
hey you will come back ooh now that
we're code gods we're ready to ready to
move on and we're gonna start with the
title of these all right the author at
the top then we're gonna do the the
title under that so how do we how do we
do this well if you recognize a pattern
here that's good we're going to use the
media class the media component again
because it makes simple how do we do the
icon or the image at the at the left and
then a title and then a paragraph to the
right so one difference though is that
we're gonna have this icon or the image
in the center right
you can't hit here but if we had
multiple lines we would still want that
image to be centered so we'll learn how
to do that too and we're ready to go
ahead and grab the media component and
one thing is that this will belong in
its own section so we'll grab that too
all right
and then one thing that we'll want to do
is it's pretty much safe to assume that
we can use this again and we can use
grid here again as well if we wanted to
refactor this we could go into here and
then make a rule for section to
automatically get rid of the padding
left in the padding right so that we
didn't have to put it here every time
but for now I'm just gonna put that like
this so here we go right here we're
gonna put an image so I'll grab the
class for that component for that do
this one all right there I change this
to 64 by 64 and there isn't a class for
every size it's just that this is
there's a few predefined classes 64 is
one of them so I'm not there's not like
a 65 by 65 and so on and so forth all
right and then here we'll swap out the
image new images and we're gonna grab
the which one was it me me me me me me
me JPEG okay great now for the content
the content what we'll do is put this in
a paragraph
and then let's see we got zenok okay so
let's put that in real quick all right
so we have a strong tag to make a bold
we have a link that goes nowhere right
now then I'm gonna force the text this
text to be gray so to do that I've got
it wrapped inside of a span and then
I've given it the class it has text
grade to just force to be a bit lighter
then I'm just using a break to break to
the next line because it belongs to the
same paragraph and then here this is
definitely recommended we're using the
time element so that search engines can
basically document when this when the
intended publication date was so for
this I've just put the same date as I
have that I published this article so
that was April April 20th all right and
the rest is pretty simple by the way
this is not the bullet character it's
actually I think I'm saying a right
interpunct right this is an octave
thorpe so alright wait so let's see how
this looks nice now you'll note if you
are OCD like me that the image is not in
the center right we've got that little
gap and Neath but not above so how do we
deal with that to feel a little while to
figure this out
but it's pretty simple we're gonna make
a general use class that we can use and
I'm gonna call it Center which this will
use flexbox
so we just got flex here and then I'm
going to Center horizontally and
vertically if you were asleep earlier we
did this like a few screencasts ago so
this really isn't anything new
do where do we put that know where we
can actually put it as right here the
reason is is because we're going to
Center
not just the figure but the text too
because the text is taller than the
figure the text will not actually have a
gap above or beneath it but because the
figure is shorter than the text the
figure will have a gap above and beneath
it now huh all right we'll turn out the
debugger and that's one problem solved
but we have one more not this huge gap
up here and you might like that
I don't so the way that we deal with
that again is the padding here because
we've started a new section Balma
basically said hey I think I want you to
have some padding - where's gonna be
lips it's gonna be a little dirty here
and just can mine that out all right so
now we've got that nice even gap above
and below the nav and then the other
part really looks ideal now on for the
title I don't know that this is the most
idiomatic way to do this it's just sort
of what I worked out and put something
inside of a div ID of it we'll do an h1
and h2 remember I want to give this
style and give them a class of title and
subtitle
remember there's modifiers to change the
size so I'll have this Cascade I'll do
is - and then is 3 and here do how to
build yeah that's great let's take a
look Oh
so when I came up with was this well we
know that sections will go ahead and
give us some padding why don't we just
use a section class here we don't need
to use the section element because
that's not semantically correct
this isn't really a new section but we
can borrow the properties from section
to style this very consistently so I
just grab this
and voila alright let's see how it looks
on a mobile device not bad
we'll do some things later to make the
text appear a little bit smaller so that
it fits better but other than that it
looks great alright in the next
screencast we're going to figure out how
to do our images which are gorgeous and
then we're going to go and do the
content in the screencast after all
right I will see you very very soon
hey welcome back we've got this
beautiful blog design and now we're
ready for these really nice images so
what's that about well what we can do is
go to the docs and we're gonna grab the
columns like we used before yeah
and then looking here I've got three so
do three columns we're going to do three
columns so do okay we have our three
columns inside of each column there's
going to be an image which could be a
link it could be just an image that's
fine and then we'll have a caption at
the bottom alright so we'll grab the
image class and then that goes inside of
each of these I will remove this guy
from now and then with you up three
images right here it's gonna be blog one
through three okay let's see what
happens
all right hang on right images yeah ooh
yeah it's okay so we forgot to make this
a grid excel right how's that look
hey looks okay so one thing that we can
do in boma is use the remember how we
use notification before to give sort of
a background well there's a few more
that we can use there's box and card I
really like card so we use it here and
that'll give us that little nice line
and a very very subtle shadow beneath it
so that's the effect that we have here
all right and then I'll just add a card
to each of these yeah so you've got this
gap which is a bit weird and then we had
this other problem we're on a mobile
device we probably would like this in
general but for images we just want it
to be wide the whole time okay let's go
and get rid of the gap first so there's
a feature called is variable which has
its own modifier I think it's like one
through a few maybe one two three four
and if we use zero that will turn off
the gap now if I want to increase that
just
little bit one or two or three let's do
two yeah so this is a really nice
feature if you don't want to completely
remove it just partly remove it all
right so we're gonna make this zero and
yeah that looks really cool how do we
deal with this there's another modifier
that we can use for columns because
columns are such an essential component
God is mobile I want you to keep your
aesthetic whether you're on a mobile or
a desktop device really quite simple and
again the reason that this isn't going
full with here is because of the
container if we really didn't like that
it wouldn't be hard for us to just
remove it all right and let's go ahead
and add a figure caption below do you
think caption a caption you know what
I'm gonna make this a figure so that
it's easier and then we can just make
these good as for now instead now I want
this to be small and Volman eise's that
so no problem and then what was the text
it was like that and you don't need to
quit because you're already here good
stewards of the Internet let's gonna
make these links that go nowhere okay
and then over here
let's who happens so okay I think we
know what we can do right we could put
the class center here all of our
problems go away yeah that's not bad and
then let's just see how this would look
with some content beneath it so just do
you like yeah right we need a we need a
we need some we need some space there so
what we needs is because this doesn't
belong to boma boma isn't giving us any
any special treatment
instead the Bommel way to do this might
be to use level allows you to align
content along level this is just
indicating that anything in it needs to
belong anywhere on the left the center
or the right and then here I can make
this a level item now basically saying I
want this thing to be a level and then
we have one item so this should be
centered and because the
belongs to MoMA he knows how to give us
that breathing room that we so desire
right before the concent was hugging it
and that was an ideal yeah so we now we
had that little space right there and
then let's make the text a little bit
lighter du has text gray and then the
last thing is there's for me I'm really
picky though I don't want this gap right
here well if we inspect it eventually
we'll find that that is a margin being
applied so it's a market being applied
to the columns what we can do is just
say remember we use is penniless before
well here I use is marginalists oh yeah
that looks so cool and of course it's
all responsive yeah all right I'll see
you in the next screencast where we add
this content and then we'll add a rule
to make this a little bit smaller on a
mobile device so that the content fits a
bit better alright see you soon
welcome back Internet now we're ready to
add the content of our blog it'd be a
pretty terrible blog we just kept it as
is and it's beautiful but it's kind of
useless so what we can do is in the
documentation there is a class that we
can use called content and you my friend
have seen this before
voila right you've seen this now content
didn't do anything for us at the time
because we just had a boring old
paragraph but now we're gonna start to
understand really how powerful content
is and content becomes especially
relevant if you want to use markdown in
your websites because doing on these
attributes all the time can be a bit
annoying sometimes you just want the
element to describe the content and for
that to be enough and so content is a
great example of this so let's do an h1
view and h2 right
so note these don't have the title or
the subtitle that we've used before
which was necessary when we wanted to
give this the style here these are just
naked HTML elements when we load them up
note that they do have a style and
that's because content is helping us out
here content is really magical because
we basically don't have to worry about
any of the trivial elements that we
might want to use it's good for
paragraphs for for lists whether they're
ordered or unordered you've got your h's
that i've showed you before we've got
block quotes and even tables it's pretty
awesome I'm gonna grab a really complete
example from the website super complete
and I'll show you what I mean
wait there are no funny classes right I
mean even have stuff like this where
there's it's it's super right and then
here we've got the sub four I mean it
stands for so maybe submarine I don't
know what that stands for okay well
let's take a look whoa what so look at
that right our blog is really gorgeous
and we have to do so little work to get
there now this let me just point that
out that is my tabs screwing with the
source code so here this is wrapped in a
pre which means basically pre process
don't cross us this text you want to
have that hug the left wall where
there's no no space to the left then
that extra space we can fix that like
that at least that's one way to fix it
I'm sure there are others anyway this is
really powerful the rate boma has done
so much heavy lifting for us and all we
had to use is HTML
I think Tim berners-lee would be like
extremely proud right now so anyway for
for our website I'm gonna go ahead and
just get rid of this instead I'll put
the content yeah now check this out this
is also why content is so powerful the
content can scale so we can have medium
content we can download content contents
pretty miraculous I mean you can have
different paragraphs in your website
have different sizes and that's not just
true for text it's true for all those
elements that I showed you just a moment
ago so boma is really freaking magical
let's say you wanted to do like is large
notification that's a really simple
example of how we combine different bola
moment classes to make like an
advertisement or like a banner and then
let's say we want to like style it right
it's really crazy how powerful boma is
anyway
let's go ahead and just leave that - I
think this medium was good and that's it
this is how you make a beautiful blog
you know in a responsive sense it's not
optimized I mean it is mobile but the
text is a bit big so I'll show you a
fascinatingly simple way that we can we
can fix that make a media query which
means I want you to override some code
in this circumstance and the
circumstance if we're rendering our
website at some max width then consider
the following rules so I'll say I want
my route element to update its font size
from the default of 16 pixels to say
like - like 414 let's just do a percent
be like 90 percent 100 percent would be
16 pixel
here 90% with not 14 but definitely
easier on the eyes and then the
circumstance is when I get to right here
so we know that this is 624 and I need
some way to say 624 plus these guys so I
can say plus 1.5 REM so remember one REM
is 16 pixels so 1.5 REM is 24 pixels and
then we knew times 248 and then we do 6
24 plus 48 and then we can say 6 72
pixels all right now when we get to that
when we cross over from a desktop or a
tablet device to what we're calling a
mobile device we get a slight update and
everything that is defined with an e/m
or in rem as its unit will also
proportionally change to its really
powerful if we wanted to go even further
totally possible to that's it you've
made a beautiful blog in like record
time and it's ence responsive and we
have like what the team lines of code
it's crazy
yeah so that's amazing now we're gonna
go all the way up to a launch page I
have stolen the Tesla Roadster page and
then made it our own using boma believe
it or not this will also be responsive
and we're gonna do it with again very
little code all right enough talk let's
get into it
I'll see you in the next screencast
hey welcome back I'm pretty excited I'm
not gonna say much about this we're just
gonna get started alright so we're gonna
use a hero I'm gonna drop the hero body
I'm just gonna start with that alright
let's take a look with the debugger
turned on and ah it's not occupying any
height so for that we can do is full
height remember we do that pretty
recently when we were designing this
webpage here we have its full height and
then here we just removed it so for this
website you can imagine that we just
have a hero and it has a modifier of is
full height okay let's take a look now
it's a darker color right if I remove
that it's a little lighter and that's
because it's a darker color on top of
our whole website that being the hero
okay
so we can start to fill in the
background so in our images we've got
one two and three and we're going to use
multiple images because we want our
website to look different on a mobile or
a tablet device so this is actually a
different image than this one I mean
it's the same picture but they've the
the tesla team has edited it so that
it's optimized for a mobile or a tablet
device I'm going to do the same here so
all we need to do is target the hero I
want to say you have a background and
Lee a background of images and then 0 1
right see what happens
oh hang on the debugger is overriding
the background yeah the first time this
happened I thought my screen was dirty
yeah it's the pictures huge right so we
need to let's Center it all right so we
need to go a bit further when you use
something called cover which means I
want this image to basically want the
image to fit inside of our websites
browser yeah that looks really good and
it is responsive in a sense but the
problem is is that on mobile devices
it's just too narrow we we can't see the
car it just doesn't look ideal
so to fix that what we can do is use a
media query actual Renee is two that are
max that are max with is a thousand 24
pixels or we're 768 pixels then wanted
to display a different background and we
just update that let's take a look hey
we move a yeah
missing the hero okay yeah so that
actually does look better
right alright so there is the desktop
right and we get to a tablet changes a
little bit and then on a mobile device
that changes even more so the point is
that these images are optimized for
different devices and that's great we'll
get a better experience as a result now
you might have noticed when I was
changing the the widths you might have
seen it like a flash of white well
that's because the background behind the
image will default to white if we're not
explicit we want that to be black which
i think is a bit more a bit more brand
we can just do this and while we're
waiting for an image to load as we're
changing the width we'll get a stroke of
black yeah so now we get like a stroke
of black if our image is still loading
which i think is just a little bit
better than white so that's it for this
screencast and the next one will focus
on the the navigation bar at the top
which of course will be mobile but in a
different sense we're gonna hide some
content in the event that we're on a
mobile device all right I'll see you
very soon
hey welcome back now we're going to add
that nap bar at the top and it's going
to require some extra CSS so I have
these helpers here and we're going to
link to them like this so it's not that
different than the way that we've linked
our debugger it's actually the same but
looking at our helpers we have a few
things that we need to add in order to
make this work
you're familiar with Center that's
nothing new but now instead of just
centering an element inside of another
one when you put it at the top the right
the bottom and the left so that's nice
and we have this special case where by
default Flex Direction sets to row and
in the event that we want it to set to
column then we can just use center
column instead might be wondering what
the heck does that mean well looking at
this the elements are following each
other across a row whereas here they're
following each other across a column so
this is an example where if we want the
elements to fall vertically we can say
Center column and that will still Center
Center the element inside of a column
all right these just make this stuff
work and then down here this is how we
can have a single single space text and
here this is if we want to hide
something if we're on a mobile device so
at a thousand 24 pixels anything that
has a class of desktop I want it to just
disappear all right so now we can add
that nav bar and to do that we're gonna
go into our Docs if I want to grab this
guy instead of body we're going to use
head here okay now the way that I
thought of this design is to have this
split into three columns so I have the
left the center and then the right
column over here we know how to do that
just go to grab the columns and then we
put that there and we know we'll have
three so I'll just put this like this
now remember when we're on a mobile
device it's gonna stack the columns so
to fix that we can just put is mobile
and I found that if we put is margin
list it'll look a lot prettier right
it's just very simple now so now I'm
going to fill in the valley
with some texts for now this hey cool so
our elements are falling vertically and
we don't want that we effectively want
them to fall horizontally if you
remember a moment ago one of our helpers
well these helpers do that because flex
direction is set to row by default
that's exactly what we want in fact we
can just leave that there and it won't
do anything at all I'll just put the
center here and that actually centers
the elements inside of their parent easy
enough we can just make that left and
right cool
it's looking better now to deal with the
fact that the text is just too close I
found that there is a class just for
this purpose so use nav bar found that
there's a class to do with this so
commute now our item mount will space it
out real nicely so we just put that
everywhere
hey great this is looking phenomenal now
on a mobile device we still have the
trouble of having all this data so the
way that we can deal with it is we'll
just put desktop here remember remember
that's this one here saying at thousand
24 pixels or less hide the content
instead of putting it here for it for
shop and sign-in
we want to keep this button here so
instead you can put desktop there and
that was really easy okay
now really all that's left is just style
so all that's really left is basically
the icon and then the style so the style
is actually pretty easy everything is a
heading and it has a text weight of fold
we also want the text to be black and I
found I can't just put has text black
here it doesn't work so instead we're
gonna be a bit lazy and just put it
right here so again if we wanted to we
could just refactor this in the style or
even go all the way to Beaumont and
customize it for our needs but for now
just do it this way alright that's
looking really good let's swap out the
text here and the text here with the
right image and icon so we know so for
so we're familiar enough so we're
familiar enough with how to do that
so we know how to do that we just grab
that and we go to here and I want to
keep our item and I don't need will link
our logo
which is right here and you'll note that
it's gonna be like crazy it's because
it's rendering the SVG's height and
width and not the desired height and
width I'm just gonna inline this for now
and we can say height one REM which kind
of works but the width is still way too
big you can see that here but a fix that
I worked out that the width to the
height was six point two five that's
great and now we just need to deal with
the hamburger so we just copied that put
it here and then there is a font awesome
icon for this now you'll note that the
text is grayish so should we say it has
text black and let's just make sure it's
all good
you might be wondering why is the height
changing so again what we'll do is we
can give it a fixed width and height
make it one two one and let's take a
look so we got the the boundaries right
but here it's just doing something funny
found that if we put the center here all
of our problems go away let's take a
look all right now to emulate that this
is active go to a rope stir and make
that way I believe that there's an is
active class that you can use or you can
make your own style or you can do this
your own way I just want to show you the
fastest way that you could so I want to
show you I just want to show you the
fastest way that you could emulate that
design now unfortunately I don't have
enough time to make this interactive but
we will finish this responsive and all
alright I'll see you in the next
screencast
hey welcome back so our sites awesome
and now we're going to add in the Tesla
and roadster text that you see at the
top to do that I'm gonna add a hero body
and then we're gonna have an each one
and in h2 whoops and you can probably
work out how we style this right we just
do and actually let's do subtitle here
because the text is smaller not bigger
and then we'll put title here yeah so
just put this in a good for now I don't
know what you're doing just put it in a
div okay so this works all the same
alright so the point is we want to have
this up at the top and we want it to be
centered so what we need to do is
basically override override
where is fault where it falls on the
page and there's a general class that we
can use to to deal with this so we can
view is overlay which means it's
position is independent from the content
on the page so even though I've got
content here the fact that it's overlaid
on top just ignores that so it's a good
start and there is a modifier has text
centered to center the text and then you
can kind of work out that we just need
to just shift it down a bit so we can
use style top and 82 was right now note
I'm not using p.m. or REM here because I
want the height to always be the same
whether we're on a mobile device or not
let's take a look so yeah that looks
great so we turn off the debugger and I
guess all that's left is this gap in
between and the the text color itself I
think you know how to do this right we
could just say hey wait a minute
I know how to do that just do has text
in black there how that worked and would
use single spaced here similar space
what do you single spaced here
remember our helper we had single space
to find because I have this other
version of it it doesn't matter where we
define it we can put it here or we can
put it up here
so the asterisk is really vital here
okay so now that content pretty much
hugs each other which is what we want
and then finally I want this to be a
little bit lighter so instead of
changing the color let's change the the
text wave it has text weight light and
yeah that gives us sort of a nice
aesthetic all right that one was easy
now last we're gonna do this like
complicated thing at the bottom and I
was like super intimidated when I went
to Tesla and was like how do I do that
turns out that this is actually pretty
intuitive if we use grid I'm sure
there's a way that you could use flexbox
but I found that grid was basically the
most expressive way to solve this
problem that's it for this screencast
see you in the final screencast
hey welcome back so our site it's
freaking awesome but it's missing the
specs at the bottom they're kind of
intricate they're a responsive design is
not like anything we've seen so far so
you might be feeling a bit intimidated
now how do you possibly do this and do
that in like 10 minutes or less and the
thing is if you have the right tool it
can be a lot easier than you imagined so
what we're gonna do is use CSS grid here
so I have a link to a file called grid
and over here I have it defined it's
just empty when you use grid to create
this design and it's going to be a lot
easier than I think you might imagine
let's go ahead and create our hero's
foot do like this and like a main
instead would be footer but it's up to
you
and we're going to follow the format
that we did before so we have everything
inside of a div just inside of the
parent so here is where we can define
our grid and I'm going to use an ID for
this it could be a class but doesn't
really matter at least not right now
now looking at this design I want you to
imagine that this is four columns and
two rows I want you to imagine that this
is four columns and two rows so you have
one two three four for the columns and
then here you have two rows right so you
have one and two and beyond that you
have five elements you have one two
three four and five
all right so we'll create five gifts I
love
so a b c d e so if we go to our grid
okay so now let's turn on the let's turn
on the debugger okay so you can see the
foot is trying to exist here but there's
just nothing to show all right so we'll
put some content yeah all right so let's
constrain the grid to say with 768 and
then let's Center here because that will
Center its child which is the grid cool
and let's just add a padding around here
okay cool so now it's got like this
little gap beneath it which is like we
have here you a grid like this and then
display grid set of grid template
columns for interview areas so areas are
pretty amazing
if you remember we have four columns and
two rows so in terms of IDs this is a B
C D and E and so what we want is to say
it that a occupies all four columns in
the first row and then BCDE each occupy
one column but span the entire row I
think I said that right all right so
here's how we can do that and say eh eh
eh eh so this is one row and then four
columns here we can say we c d e alright
let's see what happens we've got the
text at the top and then these would
each be these specs now on a mobile
device this won't do anything fancy but
I bet you have an idea of how we can do
that we can say at media max with 512
pixels and say grid when an override
grid template areas it's astonishing how
simple this is
all we need to do is remove a column and
add a row that's it I know I know it's
crazy
it's who happens so
on a mobile device you can see how the
reserve now is at the bottom and the
specs are in the center and then the
text is at the top and then that changes
depending on what we're looking at the
rest of this is really just aesthetics
so what we can do is we can say hey I
want the rose to have a gap you say grid
row gap one REM that gives us a nice
break in between and I think you know
what to do now the rest is really just
titles subtitles and an icon so I'm
gonna go in and paste them in because it
is pretty cumbersome but I bet you'll
understand all of it once I put it here
so there it is and let's just talk about
it real quick
so one of the things that you'll note is
that we're using contact column because
I want the text here to be on top of
each other if we used Center which is
flex direction row it flows left to
right and so to fix that we just say
center column take a look you'll you'll
recognize all of this code now we have a
paragraph has text centered has text
white here we have a paragraph with an
icon inside of it here I've got this
speed icon has text gray light we set a
fixed width in a fixed height which is
just a little bit smaller than the text
and we can use modifiers so we have
bearing size text right we have 1.9 as
big and then small we have s and that's
because of the and that's because we're
changing the size with the modifier is
size 5 for the reserve Now button that's
really just a link it has some modifiers
and I set the width to a hundred so that
always occupies the available width and
really that's all there is to it the
thing is with boma you can really
rapidly prototype and the code is fairly
idiomatic so I really hope you enjoyed
this course please
please share this if you think it was
valuable and if you want to reach out to
me and if you want to reach out to me
hit me up on Twitter right here you can
click my face
otherwise yeah congratulations you are
now a Bowman ninja happy coding
see ya